what is going on everyone welcome to a
data visualization with Python and
matplotlib tutorial series I'm going to
be redoing this series I have an older
version of this series on this channel
but it was actually one of the first
series I ever did and it could stand to
be updated quite a bit especially as
that we get into the more advanced
aspects of using matplotlib so here we
go we're going to go ahead and update
this series I'm not going to release
this series like I normally do where I
do like one video a day I'll be
releasing this series in rather large
chunks at a time and the reason for that
is a series doesn't really have to be
followed linearly the first few
introductory tutorials you if you're not
familiar with matplotlib you probably
should follow along linearly but then
from there you should be able to make
your choice into kind of what kind of
topics that you're specifically
interested in by that same token a lot
of times I release the series first and
then I go back and puts put the text
versions of the tutorials on Python
programming net and and this time I'm
planning to have everything released all
together so you should be able to get
the source code and the videos at the
exact same time and then you can go to
Python programming at net and kind of
figure out which of the main topics
you're mostly interested in what you're
looking for and all that so anyways in
this series we're going to cover
everything just you know from the basics
of graphing graphs with matplotlib you
know your typical scatter plots and line
graphs and bar charts stuff like that
and then we'll get into a bunch of the
customization options things like
plotting date time doing fills having
multiple plots on the same figure and
shearing axe use all kinds of stuff like
that we'll talk about base map and we'll
talk about a little bit of live graphs
and then we'll talk about 3d graphing
and then that will pretty much round out
the the series so feel free to bounce
around if you don't know the basics kind
of stick around for the basics but
otherwise you should be able to kind of
bounce around some stuff will will
reference like will teach legends and
then I'll show you how to customize
legends and then later on we may
actually customize legends based on a
legends tutorial so for that reason you
might want to fall linearly but you
shouldn't have to
so anyways first things first how do we
get Matt plot lives so there's you know
a few different ways that we can go
about actually acquiring Matt plot lives
so the first way would be via your
command prompt okay so cmd.exe
you should be able to go there and let's
open up that and if you have python 3 or
a new version of python 2 this tutorial
is going to be doing python 3 and using
python 3 but feel free to use python 2
if you want just understand there's some
changes you'll have to make and i'm not
really going to touch on those so first
of all the easiest way is if you have a
32-bit version of python which you do
have if if you just installed like the
default it doesn't matter what your
operating system is you might have a
64-bit version of Windows unless you try
to you have 32-bit Python if you want to
check you can always just type in you
know Python and read at the very top
here see my python is a 64-bit but if
your says maybe 32-bit then you have
32-bit so just to quit here so to get
matplotlib the easiest thing to do is
pip install matplotlib and that should
be it if it says pip is not a recognized
command then you'll have to give the
full path so on Windows that would be C
colon slash if you have you know for
Python and then the version I'm using
3.4 so we would say Python 34 slash
scripts slash pip install in the
matplotlib okay that should be good
enough later on you might find that it
says you don't have a module and there's
like a few of them like let's say 6 6
comes up a lot people go import
matplotlib and it says no module named 6
well you have to get 6 to any time it's
Python says hey you don't have this
module you need to get it this is how
you would get it same way you got
matplotlib so go pip install 6 ok and
that would give you 6 so that's what the
command prompt next we could use scope
here we pull over a new tab and you can
go to matplotlib gorg matplotlib
org for some reason whenever i could in
matplotlib gorg i get a lot of times
like this website like it's like it's
down all the time I don't know what the
deal is there
but anyway you can come to matplotlib
org scroll down to downloads we'll click
on the mat plot libs downloads page and
then here you get two downloads for
64-bit and 32-bit windows you can also
get the wheels you can install files
with wheels but if you're on Windows
just get this or this right win32 would
be for 32-bit one 64 or when AMD 64 for
the 64-bit there's your OS X images and
Linux you would just install via the
source so once you have matplotlib you
should be able to import matplotlib
without a problem so the next thing that
we're going to go ahead and do is to
show a really simple line graph with
matplotlib so to do that and to use
matplotlib the first thing we need to do
is import the matplotlib but more
specifically what we use is pi plot and
pi plot is the main kind of
functionality that you're going to be
using all the time you're pretty much
every application I can't think of one
that is not going to be using PI plots
so you're going to do this a lot so
you're going to need this import mat
plot Lib pie plot as p LT we do that
just to shorten it and that's a standard
so most people shortened pie plot as p
LT so if you're looking at other
people's code you can kind of you'll
understand that you won't have to
usually trace that back to their import
so you'll just know p LT it's kind of
like with numpy people important um PI
as NP everyone does that so it's a good
idea to do that too so people can
understand your code when you need help
so import map outlived up PI plot as p
LT and that's fine the next thing that
we're going to go ahead and do is is
plot so when we go to plot we invoke the
PI plot module which we say is PL T and
then we say dot and plot and when you go
to plot you plot X's and you plot wise
now we don't really have anything for X
and for y so let's fill those in let's
just create two lists so we'll say X is
1
two three and then why you didn't pretty
much say whatever you want we could save
fives not 76574 okay so our graph does
something interesting case okay so we
plot there and then now what happens
with graphics is everything is drawn to
a background first and then when
everything is all ready to be shown
that's when we bring forward whatever
has been you know we've been working on
the background matplotlib is no
different so in the background this
graph has been drawn but we need to
bring it to the forefront so the way
that we do that is just with a simple
PLT dot show empty parameters and that's
it so now we can save and run this and I
suppose we wait for a moment
here we go and there is our graph so
we'll be talking a little bit more about
how this works but basically you know
you've got this graph it's a line and
you've got like this kind of a GUI
window that you have and then you've got
these buttons down here so we can run
through those buttons real quick first
of all you can resize the graph no
problem you should be able to move that
around a lot then you've got these first
three buttons we can't really do
anything with them just yet so we'll
talk about those at the end we'll start
with this little cross here if you click
that you can now click on your graph
click and hold and like drag the graph
round a little bit okay so that's one
thing then you've got like the zoom so
you can zoom in to a specific area if
you wanted you can also zoom out so that
was with a left click and hold to draw
the triangle you know the same thing by
right click and hold and this instead
will zoom out so we're able to zoom out
that way
then you've got configure subplots right
now this doesn't really mean much to us
but we can move a few things like you'll
notice there's a lot of empty space on
the left the right the bottom and the
top we can kind of we can use this to
adjust that space and later on we'll use
it because you can actually program in
these values to change them so we'll
talk about that when that comes up then
you have this save of the figure this is
just so you can actually save the image
or even a vector of the graph and a
bunch of other options too then we go
back to
these buttons so first you've got this
little home that will return you to the
original view so you click that and now
you're at the original view everything's
back to normal you can use the back to
previous view to go back one you can
keep hitting this and keep going back
conversely you can go forward right and
go back to the original views before
that so those are the basics of
matplotlib hopefully you guys are up to
this point if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video